When The Handmaid's Tale premiered on Hulu,
you might have noticed quite a few familiar
faces—including Yvonne Strahovski, who plays
Serena Joy.
If you're wondering where you've seen Strahovski
before, well you're in luck—we've put together
a list of her most visible roles over the
years.
Chuck
For five years, Strahovski played CIA agent
Sarah Walker on the NBC action spy comedy
Chuck.
Agent Walker is one of the agents assigned
to protect Chuck after he accidentally downloads
secret government information into his brain.
While her primary mission was to keep Chuck
safe from the rogue groups trying to capture
him, her cover as Chuck's "girlfriend" eventually
became the real deal.
Strahovski's character on Chuck was a fan
favorite, and she went on to win both a Teen
Choice Award and two TV Guide Awards for her
work.
Mass Effect
Strahovski first lent her voice to the character
of Miranda Lawson in the mobile spin-off game
Mass Effect Galaxy, then hit the video game
franchise full-time in Mass Effect 2 and the
follow-up, Mass Effect 3.
But she provided more than a voice for the
character — Miranda was actually designed
to look like Strahovski.
"They scanned my face into it and then they
made me brunette.
And then the body is not mine.
The body is not mine!"
Strahovski was nominated for a Spike Video
Game Award for her role as Lawson, and Lawson
has frequently been included in "Hottest Video
Game Character" lists.
If that Mass Effect movie project can ever
get off the ground, here's hoping Strahovski
will be back.
Killer Elite
After years of acting mostly in TV shows,
Yvonne Strahovski landed one of her first
big film roles with 2011's Killer Elite, where
she starred as Jason Statham's love interest.
Their attempt to start a romance runs into
a few roadblocks along the way, however, and
they both get caught up in a deadly game of
cat and mouse with international killers.
Killer Elite wasn't a massive hit with critics,
but it showcased Strahovski's acting abilities
and primed her career for even bigger roles
to come.
The Guilt Trip
In a twist on the traditional road trip movie,
The Guilt Trip chronicles the cross-country
adventure of Joyce and her adult son, Andy,
played by Barbra Streisand and Seth Rogen.
Along the way, of course, two discover a lot
more about themselves than they planned.
Yvonne Strahovski plays a small but memorable
role as one of Andy's old girlfriends who
rescues them when their car breaks down.
While it's a relatively small part, Strahovski
definitely helps Streisand turn the awkward
up to 11 during this cringe-inducing scene.
Dexter
Showtime's serial-killer drama Dexter ran
for eight seasons, and one of the highlights
of the last two of those seasons was the introduction
of Hannah McKay, played by Strahovski, a woman
with secrets just as dark as Dexter's.
McKay's complicated romantic relationship
with Dexter evolves until the final episode,
and eventually comes to a head as the two
killers attempt to flee the country together.
We're not sure how many real relationships
start with attempted murder, but on Dexter,
what else would you expect?
24: Live Another Day
Although Strahovski played a CIA agent in
both Chuck and 24, the character of Kate Morgan
couldn't be more different from the light-hearted
role of Sarah Walker on Chuck.
In 24: Live Another Day, Morgan is the widow
of another CIA agent who committed suicide
after he was accused of treason.
True to the show's style, Kate Morgan is a
gritty, serious character who doesn't pull
any punches as she ruthlessly tracks down
Jack Bauer and works to uncover his true motives.
Along the way, she learns the shocking truth
behind her husband's alleged treason.
I, Frankenstein
This action-fantasy film drops the reanimated
monster of Victor Frankenstein into an epic
struggle between good and evil that makes
its way to the modern day.
Caught in the middle of this conflict is Yvonne
Strahovski's character, Terra, a scientist
conducting experiments on reanimation for
Naberius, played by Bill Nighy—not realizing
his true nature as a demon.
Frankenstein's monster must do his best to
not only defeat Naberius and foil his plans,
but also save Terra before the demon prince
can use her to create an army of undead.
The Astronaut Wives Club
This ABC miniseries aired in 2015 and chronicled
the lives of the wives of the "Mercury Seven"—America's
first astronauts.
Set during NASA's most tumultuous period,
the show covers everything from the first
manned American flight in space to the first
moon landing.
While obviously dramatized for television,
it's an intriguing look at women thrust into
the spotlight simply because of who they were
married to.
Strahovski co-stars as Rene Carpenter, wife
of Scott Carpenter, who flew in the second
orbital mission.
Manhattan Night
In this crime drama from 2016, Strahovski
pairs up with Adrien Brody, who plays Porter,
a crime reporter in New York City.
The pair start an illicit romance when Strahovski's
character, Caroline, contacts him to uncover
information about her husband's recent mysterious
death.
Soon, they find themselves caught up in a
mystery bigger than they'd imagined.
Manhattan Night is a stylish modern noir that
didn't make any big waves on its release,
but it showed off Strahovski's acting range.
And now that she's co-starring in Hulu's hit
series The Handmaid's Tale, there's no telling
where Yvonne Strahovski's career will go next.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!